[Musique]
une convention a été signée entre le
département et la civis ce mardi 8
décembre permettant la mise en oeuvre du
pacte de solidarité de lutte
anti-vectorielle 2020-2021 ses pattes a
pour objectif le renforcement de la
lutte contre la dengue sur l'île
nous sommes au début à nouveau de la
saison sèche avec l'arrivée des pluies
des chaleurs on sait mieux que le
moustique porteur de la dengue va
recommencer à circuler et donc il nous
convient de protéger nos populations
pour protéger nos populations
on veut passer des conventions avec les
pc qui sont chargés de la collecte et du
traitement des déchets et lorsqu'on
accorde une subvention à le pc à la
civis
on va le faire aussi aux quatre autres
intercommunalités de lille
tout simplement parce que ce sont elles
qui sont les actrices de la collecte du
traitement de déchets donc c'est pour ça
que nous avons entamé ce travail avec
les opci pour faire en sorte que la
réunion soit plus proche qu'on enlève
ces tas d'ordures ces carcasses de
véhicules ces vieux pneus qui sont des
gîtes larvaires potentiels et donc le
travail en commun sera plus efficace
c'est quoi cela que nous travaillons
avec eux la civis aujourd'hui la
convention représente une enveloppe de
750 mille euros et le département va
apporter 600 mille euros 950000 civis
600 me le département pour rappel depuis
2010 est plus de 40 mille malades de la
dengue ont été identifiés entraînant
1500 hospitalisation et 42 décès
[Musique]